[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment
of harry potter theory in today's video
i wanted to introduce a potential new
video format
where i discuss the events of particular
days in the harry potter story
the harry potter books span a very large
period of time
which means that there are so many
significant dates worth mentioning
i thought it could be fun to once a week
to a couple of times a week make videos
outlining the important events of some
of these dates
starting with today may 2nd these videos
won't replace regular content
they'll be more of a short format extra
thing may 2nd
is one of the most important dates in
harry potter history do you know why
well today marks 23 years since the
battle of hogwarts
the day that lord voldemort himself was
defeated by harry
in their epic duel interestingly enough
this
is actually a significant day in muggle
history as well
as it represents the fall of berlin in
world war ii
knowing rowling this was probably
intentional but for now
back to harry potter the battle of
hogwarts is both terrible and amazing
all at the same time
i say this because while voldemort fell
it certainly came as a price
the lives of many of our favorite
characters were lost during this battle
including remus lupin nymphadora tonks
snape
fred weasley lavender brown and many
more
of course if you're more on the evil
side then you may have been more sad
about the losses of people like
bellatrix and well voldemort himself
this battle
marked the end of the second wizarding
war and introduced an era of peace
a time when all of wizardkind could
sleep easy knowing that no imminent
threat
was brewing while the battle of hogwarts
was certainly the most important event
corresponding with this day
it just so happens that another rather
significant event fell on this date
as well just in a different year
remember bill and fleur
weasley delacore well they had children
and according to canon one of their
children victoire weasley
was born on the same day in the early
2000s
victoire was named as such due to the
significance of this date
and how it corresponded with the defeat
of lord voldemort
and that's it for this video do you guys
want more of this in the future
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
you're a wizard harry
you